I don't want to age you but you were
born the year the original shaft came
out what uh what you don't look at
obviously but what point did you
actually like first see it and find out
about and kind of was your first
impression of it thought I was like
around 9 or 10 oh wow okay I still had
to kind of sneak into it but you had to
see what everybody else was talking
about so I finally got a chance to check
it out
and what was like when you when you
found out that they're making another
movie and you I assumed you pitched it
well no actually the script was sent to
me okay can you bears I wrote an
incredible scrub and I just laughed out
loud with reading it and just knew that
um you know I didn't see myself doing a
shaft you know or didn't seem like the
the exact way to go but at the same time
I saw read the script knew I could bring
my voice to it and bring something to it
and luckily they allowed me to do it
well it's funny cuz you did it to
ride-along movies and I figured I think
that almost every action comedy or any
action movie since shaft is kind of
influenced in some ways I'm sure IceCube
ever seen and influenced but so but you
need to think of yourself as a shaft of
director well you know all the other
shafts are they're pretty much dramas
and when I read the script I knew that
they wanted to go this direction where
they wanted some action you know some
action slash comedy to it and I just
felt like you know what I could respect
what it where it's coming where what it
you know means it's so many and I also
could bring my own talented and what uh
what did John Singleton Shafter what
what kind of influences influences your
own approach to it I mean obviously
there's a lot of funnier it's a pretty
much a straight comedy almost but we're
kind of influenced you from his movie
that you wanted to bring to this one
well look I mean you had Sam in his
first um you know move with a bean shaft
and I just wanted to kind of um from
there just make sure the character was a
consistent and you know and it's and
it's quite easy for that when you have
somebody like Sam Jackson playing the
roles again and I just wanted to kind of
fail miles we have a few verbal cues in
there that come from the old the old
film or the film that John did
and I can't wait for people to see it
and also Jesse getting Jesse to play the
son of shaft which was originally called
the original title of a movie what was
uh it was a long look to find someone or
was it sort of like we looked at a lot
of actors we've Jesse finally came in
and we at some point wherever to put him
in a room with Sam and we just saw that
Sam could you know their chemistry
together was just great and Jesse could
keep up with salmon and it was it was
awesome and so we had decided to go with
Jesse you uh you have some great women
in the movie obviously Kenny I wrote
some great roles for women this time
around we've had women in the movies
before but not like this how this kind
of impact obviously you work with
Katrina before I was she like a
no-brainer get her back sort of totally
no brain I knew I needed a strong woman
especially even in Regina's part as well
as Alexandra ships part we just know we
needed strong women if the wit and the
men were gonna be this kick-ass the
women had to be just as kick-ass as they
and I know Regina could just bring
something up fun to it uh I knew she
could also curse just as good as Sam
Jackson so at the same time or you're
working at a Tom and Jerry movie I saw
the same book on wheel which was
absolutely amazing there was no thing I
wish I wish they were released it's just
such a fun thing and it was such a like
one thing so what goats what are you
kind of bringing the Tom and Jerry this
for this time or a but it's the Turk and
you gotta find a new audience a lot of
people who don't know what Tom and Jerry
is yeah we're just gonna have a lot of
fun we're gonna keep for those who do
know Tom and Jerry we're gonna give you
what you're expecting they are they're
gonna look like they're they're suppose
to and we're having a lot of fun with
the auxiliary characters that are around
them as well and I'm just gonna try to
you know make it a make it as
entertaining as possible now I ask you
there's been a monopoly movie in some
form of development for probably about
20 years or more you're the latest
person to kind of approach IV I mean how
is that something that will really
happen is this what you've been
developing and we sure we sure hope so
we've got a great idea
you know we've got a you got a rider
we're looking at right now to bring it
to fruition and on and if we do you know
if we do our job I think will give you
something that you know quite like